mmm that is so good i'm very impressed
[Music]
on this week's episode of the burger
show my two favorite things in the world
come head to head
burgers and breakfast before my life
revolved around burgers 24
7 i was perfecting egg sandwiches and
let me tell you
combining the two mwah chef's kiss
so what makes the ultimate breakfast
burger i'm going to tackle that issue
with one of my favorite chefs
molly baz and put our culinary chops to
the test
she's going to make a delicious smash
patty breakfast sandwich
and i'm going to show off my crispy hash
brown spicy
bacon burger yeah dude get ready
[Music]
[Applause]
we're back burger show baby and
we're with molly boss welcome i hear you
just moved to los angeles or
how long has it been now it's been a
year so we love it so much that we
bought a house here that's so big yeah
that's so important congratulations
lots of congratulations in the air
because your new book is out there she
is
hey and it's dodger blue shout out to
los angeles
i like to call it molly blue but okay
molly blue dodger blue she's in la
and that's her book buy it so have you
been able to like
check out the wonderful world of burgers
in los angeles because you know
we kind of hold it down right now in the
burger world i
honestly have been making a lot of my
own burgers i mean obviously we're all
home
i made more smash burgers in quarantine
than ever in my life and that has a lot
to do with the fact that
like i could make them outside people
are making just such delicious burgers
and that's what we're gonna do today
which i'm super excited because
the beginning of my career was all about
breakfast breakfast sandwiches breakfast
burgers and then now
it's all about the burger so we're gonna
mash them up mash them up and we're
gonna make some for each other to try
i call it the smash patty breakfast
sando
and it was only after creating it that i
was like that's a breakfast burger like
that's just me eating a
burger breakfast but i'm using sausage
so it's a burger and spirit
i'm super excited let's just get started
let's do it shall we
we shall but i also was gonna make a
side smushed and crispy
salt and vinegar potatoes that sounds
delicious and so i was thinking you
could do that
cool bring those to a boil like heavily
seasoned water
how seasoned like ocean really [ __ ]
okay
that seems like the right amount of salt
if you ask me
so this is a breakfast burger it
starts with pork sausage i have pork
sausage here that
is already been rolled into a nice
perfect little ball to smash
but you provided me with a tortilla
press and you oh
yeah i mean it smashes so this is what
we're looking at perfection right
where did the inspiration of this burger
come from
it's like the mashup of a smash burger
and then a egg mcmuffin
oh okay you know yeah smash stack
mcpuffin that's pretty genius
i'm gonna do the like moat style thinly
sliced
onion situation so i'm using a mandolin
i would actually go even thinner like
yes paper paper thin like not good
enough
onions are sliced and then here's the
thing i'm gonna do
half of the onions on top of the burger
but then i'm also
gonna do raw onions and i'm tossing them
with hot sauce so they're kind of like
macerating like
pickling and hot sauce is super
important for breakfast i think
very important your brain needs coffee
yep your palate
needs hot sauce to wake up 100 aligned
okay we have more hot sauce going into
the mayonnaise because i'm just making
like a hot mayo
scene this little joji thing is gonna
get
slathered on now just a little bit so
we're going right on
here what makes this a breakfast
sandwich there's eggs on it
wow gorgeous eggs so just whisking that
and then i'm seasoning them
with salt and pep these guys are good a
little crispy
nice so i'm gonna season this um sausage
patty
not super crazy because breakfast
sausage is pre-seasoned
true you hear this is the sids and then
immediately allah george moats because
it's important that he get credit for
this
the thinly sliced white onions right on
top i love that you said that
he's freaking genius yeah so if you see
this method you know where it came from
you know what time it is yeah
it's george most i'm going in
flipping a crust on that and then i'm
adding american
cheese obviously and then turning it off
molly would you agree that american
cheese yes or yes
is the best cheese for breakfast or
burgers the only
did i try this with a lot of other
cheeses yes did i land on american
100 i love that because we had brad on
the show
oh god whatever he is like who the [ __ ]
said american cheese is the best cheese
and he's like
it's pissed me off forever
you know americans cheese i didn't have
a say in this
brad and i was just like i did
oh my god it was good oh i was gonna
come over there
you're ready to go i'm gonna go back
here so i'm gonna make
fast and dirty scrambled eggs it's like
hot pan let's go
30 seconds we're done i call it diner
style eggs and then it's like a
push and pull and it sets really quickly
and then boom we're done
and i'll take these over and i can go
back to your station all right okay do
you want to see the burger reveal it's
gorgeous okay let's do it
awesome is that beautiful ooey gooey i
have my
english muffin and i'm adding more of
that hot sauce mayo
some of these scrambled eggs the
freaking level up right now the
macerated onions with the hot sauce and
then a pile of arugula
for health or whatever sure the burger
looks
it looks [ __ ] good those potatoes
that you boiled for me then got smashed
and then they got drizzled with olive
oil seasoned with more salt and pepper
and roasted until crispy
we're gonna finish it now with this
vinegar sour cream
that's gonna be served alongside this
burger so i'm doing like a dollop
okay a little swooshy sitch and then the
potatoes
are nice and crispy and they're on top
here look at that bad boy it looks
amazing
[Music]
that is so good the spicy onions is so
go on next level the patty the crispness
the cheese
combined unreal as soon as you bite it
it slaps the golden arches this is like
this is how
an egg mcmuffin should be let's try
these potatoes
okay oh did we hear that crunch remember
i've never thought of putting vinegar
into sour cream
and that is so good
vinegar and potatoes an amazing
breakfast
sando slash burger that means a lot
coming from you honestly
and now i feel all the pressure because
i gotta make you one it's your turn i
don't know what you're making which is
the funnest part of this date
i'm not gonna make my burger i'm gonna
eat this okay
i live by this rule and it's
breakfast cannot be complicated totally
right
that's why i feel like a breakfast
burger is like a perfect
fusion of things because the burger is
like in its very essence
an easy thing to expect exactly that
said i'm gonna roll
into how i usually do a breakfast
sandwich
and it usually starts with coffee and i
got a vietnamese espresso press here
oh [ __ ] okay some condensed milk cafe du
monde it's basically just coffee and
chicken i'm gonna pour this in
gorgeous boom so i have this
really delicious sweet bun from like the
local chinese bakery i buy these by the
dozen and then i made
a patty that's 50 percent beef
and 50 bacon oh [ __ ] okay yeah so
i'm using cheddar what because i feel
that the flavor of cheddar for morning
it's a punch
okay i thought we just talked about
american cheese but okay yeah no i think
it's an undisputed champion of cheese
don't get me wrong
but since exa only uses sharp cheddar
yeah i'm gonna stick with that because
that's what i'm known for
egg [ __ ] i get it i get it and then i
have hash browns here just
regular shredded hashbrowns that you can
get in your grocery store but what i do
is i let it fall out for like an
hour and then i add potato starch so
that i can turn them into
these little balls right here so the
starch kind of are you gonna
and it's gonna go yeah we'll start with
the hash brown ball
and then i just smash it wow okay so
while we crisp up this hash brown
i'm gonna make my sauce okay similar to
yours
i'm gonna start off with some scallions
the spice element that i have
i've been really [ __ ] with serranos
lately because it kind of gives it that
like
spicy but fresh bite to it a dollop
of mayo and then a dollop of sour cream
and then that's it so i'm doing a
marbleized egg
oh love that that's a real lazy man's
egg that's a really a breakfast
spirited egg i'm gonna take this guy off
and then i'm gonna go with the egg
go i'm just gonna give it a spin like
that yeah
i mean that's why they call it marble
right because of the streaks of yellow
and i'm going to shape it to my bun
and then i'm going to give it a quick
flip 10 seconds
yep flip it again and that's it that's
the egg
then now it's burger time okay let's do
it wow
beautiful i am curious what you're doing
are you like
making frico over there no so basically
because
this cheese takes forever to melt it's
cheddar jump starting it
wow i've never seen the techniques what
we do at accent
so smart but then you eat that part
right this is like the chef's snack
we'll leave that there that's for me
later and then we're gonna build let's
just build this burger let's just do it
the bottom bun aka the heel and then
we're gonna put some
of the sour cream serrano and scallion
sauce yum
our hash brown then our marbleized egg
then our smashed 50 50 bacon patty and
then
we'll dollop it again i can smell that
smoky bacon
very fragrant i have my breakfast burger
i'm going to cut in half
voila look at the steam look at those
scallions
i'm just really here for the scallions
it's like it smells so right like a
baked potato vibe going on right there
yes
i can't get my day started unless i have
this that cup of ice is really iconic
looking
top it with a little bit of milk should
i dive in yeah
that's the burger show breakfast burger
what do we think
oh my god that burger blend it's good so
good
it's 50 50 but i feel like it tastes
like bacon
the serranos are like holding this down
they're like crunchy
yeah and the freshness and the heat that
is
very delicious how do you like the bud i
love the bun there's so much savory [ __ ]
happening here that the sweet bun is
just like
super perfectly squishy what a genius
burger bun
so good is it super sweet it's not super
sweet it's perfectly sweet
okay good like nailed it i'm glad you
like it so there it is
the burger show breakfast burger i'm so
glad you got to try it because
i'm very impressed breakfast burgers
need to be a thing
molly and i are campaigning today starts
now all you new burger pop-ups need to
turn it into
a breakfast burger thing yeah you need
to open a little earlier and you need to
make a breakfast
exactly that's it folks
everyone make sure you buy her book
burger show it's a wrap we're done
[Music]
nice
what's up burger world thank you for
watching make sure you hit that like
button
smash that subscribe button ring that
notification bell
if not for me for the burgers
i love you